when is it okay to not be brave
never I think bravery comes out of
selflessness the Granite Mountain
hotshots are a great example of what
being brave is all about we should yeah
be very appreciative of what these guys
do because they are putting themselves
in in pretty hairy situations to help
people they've never even met who might
not be firefighters going you know these
guys are so brave you're going right to
where most of us would run away from
bravery isn't the absence of fear real
bravery is having fear recognizing it
and moving through it that's what
separates these guys that's what makes a
hotshot a hotshot or a first responder
or a first responder they're going right
into it and that's something that can be
aspiring as we face our challenges of
our own life you know they really are
our heroes the bravery that people can
tap into for others is very moving to me
we're all in this thing together speak
up for that person that you feel like
doesn't have a voice and try and go
through a little more of a healing
process because if you turn on the news
that's what we need right now it can be
a teacher it can be an activist it can
be anyone who is being true to what they
believe in I'm doing my best to let that
sense of bravery inspire me to take
action and create the kind of world that
I want for myself and my kids and my
grandkids
[Music]